divide en 99 puntos 0 61 entre 100 y en
este vídeo lo que buscaré es enseñarles
cómo algunos truquitos o una forma mucho
más rápida un atajo para que ustedes
puedan hacer las divisiones de decimales
cuando están multiplicando o dividiendo
entre o por una potencia de 10 en este
caso vamos a empezar con las
multiplicaciones si nosotros
multiplicamos 99.0 6 1 por 10 haríamos
más grande el número están de acuerdo
estamos multiplicando así es que
moveremos el punto decimal hacia la
derecha un valor posicional porque
estamos multiplicando por 10 de esta
manera terminaríamos con 990 puntos 61
lo hicimos más grande de 99 puntos 0 61
a 990 puntos 61 qué pasa con las
divisiones con las divisiones tendremos
un comportamiento hacia el otro lado
tenemos 99.61 /
y lo que haremos es mover el decimal
hacia la izquierda en este caso una sola
vez porque estamos dividiendo entre 10
así haremos más pequeño el número
teníamos 99 puntos 0 61 y nuestros
resultados eran 9 puntos 9 061 será más
pequeño en nuestro ejercicio nos dicen
99 puntos 0 61 divide lo entre 100 en
este caso nos moveremos hacia la
izquierda dos veces porque estamos
dividiendo entre 10
y otra vez entre 10 es decir dos veces
entre 10 para dividir entre 100
y de esta manera terminaremos con un
número mucho más pequeño nuestra
respuesta será punto 9 9 061 y agregar
un 0 aquí al principio para hacerlo más
fácil de leer esta será nuestra
respuesta y efectivamente será un número
mucho más pequeño